la unión europea se niega a reconocer al
gobierno talibán en afganistán pero sí
que accede a conversar el sábado de
martes tenemos una reunión con miembros
de la unión europea
bruselas exige el cumplimiento de cinco
puntos para reanudar relaciones no
convertirse en base del terrorismo bajo
esta premisa en 2001 eeuu inició la
guerra que terminó entonces con el
gobierno talibán el respeto de los
derechos humanos su vulneración es uno
de los mayores temores desde que el 15
de agosto el grupo talibán se hiciese
con el control de kabul la capital un
gobierno inclusivo y representativo
la mayoría del ejecutivo sigue siendo de
la etnia pastún la principal en
afganistán y formado íntegramente por
hombres el libre acceso a la ayuda
humanitaria de la cual depende gran
parte de la población cuando más de un
tercio vive con menos de dos dólares al
día y permitir la salida de los afganos
en riesgo ante la llegada del integrismo
religioso
integrismo que pese a haber llegado de
forma moderada busca revertir el bloqueo
económico internacional la unión europea
advierte de una catástrofe humanitaria
que puede afectar al menos un millón de
niños para fin de año por lo que
bruselas tendrá que enfrentar una
contradicción aumentar ayudas económicas
sin reconocer a los talibanes nosotros
no podemos esperar y observar tenemos
que actuar y con rapidez la unión
europea busca evitar desde lo económico
un desplazamiento masivo hacia sus
fronteras mientras organizaciones como
acnur apuntan a la violencia crónica
como otra de las principales causas del
desplazamiento de 6 millones de afganos